- Well, Mother's Day is around the corner,
so what are you getting your mom?
Don't let her down.
- Well, you know, it used
to be when I was younger,
anything made her happy.
I could pick dandelions out of the yard.
I could bake her something.
I could make her pancakes
but now all she wants
is celebrity male attention.
(audience giggling)
- What?
- [Ron] That's all she
cares about because--
- What does that mean?
- I took her to meet Blake
Shelton at "The Voice"
one year.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And since then--
- [Kelly] Since then she gave
up celebrities?
- She gave up regular man.
(laughing)
She gave, all she wants is celebrities.
All she will talk about it, that's all.
She's touched Justin Timberlake.
- She's touched.
(laughing)
- His security tried to stop her.
They could not, they could not.
And right now her big,
the gift she wants me
to find a way to get LeBron James for her.
So that's partially--
- I love your mother right now.
The three men you just mentioned
couldn't be more different from the other.
- No, she says that she gets older,
you know, she's just open,
she's like Baskin Robbins.
Give me a little spoon for every flavor.
(laughing)
- She wants to try
every flavor, I love it.